okay but do I look in the camera no all
right now knock it off
stupid-ass grab-ass and touchy-feely
bull goddamn I told you they was rotten
I am pond abyss Jackson the principal
here at clortho's
vince clortho high formality here's a
bunch of stuff that we confiscated just
this week you don't have to show them
that here's a wand with a silencer on it
why but I ask again why one or five
girls in this school is pregnant with a
demon baby the babies are evil but the
mothers that good kids as we say at
clortho's there's never a portal that
cannot be opened with ingenuity and
respect how you're gonna be using an
invisible cloak when I can see you're
tagging the damn wall dime bag of pixie
dust contraband let's see here's the
thing the kids know that the only way to
fly
wizard pepper unbelievable get your ass
out of my office I will turn you into a
spider bear good kid hogwarts and
clortho's clortho's and hogwarts they go
hand-in-hand the best top two wizarding
schools there are but you know out of
these two schools we each have a
strength we do score a little bit lower
on our standardized tests than Hogwarts
but there is a cultural bias we may not
have a huge endowment like they get over
at Hogwarts and yes some of the teachers
have to buy their own newts eyes or bat
wings
okay got transformed into a cat they
can't even afford a changing back this
young man's name is Jamar normally and
not allowed to touch the students like
this when they're in human form but when
their cat we just have at it
sports everybody loves sports and
everybody the hallways are bluster with
the conversation of our quidditch a
perfect teammate back here riding mops
we got two little nicks on swiffers
luster when all is said and done the
average clortho student-- I said this
mother sometimes the kids think it's
cute to turn themselves into a rat sneak
into my office play a little joke on me
who is that Tyrone is that is that no
that's an actual rat
you